je vous le redis encore une fois vous
devez garder espoir en aucun cas ne
perdaient espoir
si vous n'avez pas l'espoir si on le
retrouve aujourd'hui cela va me coûter
entre 500 et 1000 roupies
oui mais le plus important c'est
vraiment de garder espoir ne perd pas
espoir
vous ne le retrouverai peut-être pas
aujourd'hui mais tôt ou tard ça doit
arriver
vous voyez
[Applaudissements]
si un enfant va à l'école et disparaît
alors ce que quelqu'un l'a kidnappée si
cette tendance se maintient cela va
devenir un énorme problème dans le monde
entier
on prend ces incidents avec le plus
grand sérieux le fait que ces enfants
proviennent de familles extrêmement
pauvre aggrave encore la situation
ces gens préfèrent ne pas aller à la
police avec leurs problèmes
alfacam en effet un manège tourne même
si nous libérons quatre ou cinq fille
des griffes des criminels beaucoup
d'autres demeurons en captivité et nous
ne serons jamais rien à leur sujet nous
savons qu'il y à une jeune népalais qui
a fugué une autre mineure elles sont
déjà parties elles ont pris le train il
y à un homme qui les accompagnent ils
les emmènent probablement à bombay
[Musique]
à
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
où vas tu as billard avec qui avec papa
et où est ton papa
vous êtes son père
[Applaudissements]
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
la daurade pour qui il est pour toi
c'est son père ils vont chez sa mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monfils qui sonne à 13 ans il a disparu
le 11 du mois dernier
il portait une chemise blanche et un
pantalon bleu si quelqu'un sait où il se
trouve
veuillez le signaler immédiatement aux
services de police de ghaziabad si jeune
il a 13 ans seulement
[Musique]
vous avez vu ce garçon pardon avez vous
vu ce garçon
[Musique]
messieurs monfils est perdu je suis
désespéré je ne dors pas la nuit je
passe mes journées à errer dans la ville
mais parfois je me sens tellement
terrifié que je reste assis tout
simplement sur le bas côté de la route
et c'est tout
[Musique]
j'interroge tout le monde à propos de
mon fils si vous le voyez quelque part
dites le moi j'irai là bas le chercher
tout de suite où que ce soit je me
rendrai il s'appelle qishan il s'appelle
qichen tout ce qui importe c'est de le
retrouver
c'est comme si je brûle à l'intérieur je
n'arrive pas à travailler normalement
[Musique]
mais je ne veux rien faire je rentre à
la maison et je ne pense qu'à mon enfant
je sors et je pense toujours à lui je ne
peux ni manger ni boire
[Musique]
le matin je sors de chez moi je circule
en vélo dans la ville
je cherche mon fils je colle des avis de
recherche
je n'ai aucun plan précis je ne cherche
pas dans un endroit particulier la
police est à sa recherche et c'est bien
mais ils font leur travail à eux et nous
on cherche notre enfant nous mêmes dans
les rues et les ruelles dans les
mosquées et les temple sikh
tout ce que je peux faire pour mon fils
personne ne le fera
non
[Musique]
à deux ou trois heures du matin quand je
m'assoupis je remonte sur mon vélo et je
rentre à la maison
le top 10 allez goûter basané sont à
terme général pour les filles les tribus
indiennes dit listés sont souvent
victimes de la traite d'êtres humains ou
ce programme et ses fils en instruction
il revenant de familles très pauvres
sont des proies faciles pour les
criminels sont souvent attirés dans les
grandes villes
sous prétexte de trouver un emploi
là-bas sont victimes d'exploitation
sexuelle et psychologique
[Musique]
l'état de jharkhand est relativement
jeune il a été fondé dans le nord ouest
de l'inde en l'an 2000 seulement on dit
que depuis lors environ un million de
jeunes filles de castes inférieures ont
été enlevés
[Musique]
cette femme estime que sa vie est
toujours menacée c'est pour ça que nous
avons décidé de flouter son visage et de
changer son
[Musique]
mais la dame je m'appelle semaine par là
je suis de 15h10 pattani
il m'est arrivé quelque chose que je ne
sais pas comment raconter
je suis parti en 2014 je suis revenu en
2015 et puis deux ou trois ans plus tard
je suis reparti on va faire je ne
pouvais pas trouver de travail
je voulais faire des études mais je n'ai
pas eu une telle opportunité
mon père buvait et ne se souciait pas de
nom c'est pour ça que j'ai quitté la
maison
nous sommes six frères et soeurs maman
travaillait déjà dur pour nous nourrir
si mes petits frères pouvaient recevoir
une éducation
il pourrait avoir un destin différent je
vais gagner de l'argent pour les aider
je pensais et donc je suis parti
ils sont venus me chercher ici à mandera
j'ai rencontré un homme qui devait
m'accompagner personne n'était au
courant
personne ne savait que j'étais parti
ensuite nous nous sommes rendus à ranchi
de là nous sommes allés voir le mari de
ma soeur et il a dit que je devais aller
voir cet homme j'ai protesté parce que
je ne le connaissais pas j'ai dit à mon
beau-frère que j'aurais préféré y aller
avec lui
[Musique]
j'avais peur parce que je n'avais jamais
voyagé aussi loin de la maison
oui j'avais peur mais qu'est ce que je
pouvais faire
je pensais tout le temps à ma maison et
à mes parents mais que faire ça ne sert
à rien d'avoir peur
je suis venu ici pour travailler
[Musique]
je ne voulais pas faire ce qu'on me
demandait ce n'est pas pour moi il ne me
croyait pas il ne faisait confiance
kohler je les suppliais de m'écouter et
cet homme me répétait une seule et même
chose fais ce que je te dis
il me battait ces gens ce sont de vrais
ordures ils me frappaient fréquemment la
femme du propriétaire me frapper elle
aussi elle m'insultait j'étais mal
nourris il m'insultait sans cesse
[Musique]
j'ai passé le premier mois et d une
femme qui vivait déjà la tuer les
parties je leur ai dit que je ne ferais
pas tout ça elle m'a dit que nous étions
parents qu on était une famille j'ai dû
travailler pour eux pendant un an puis
ils ont commencé à me battre et il me
faisait regarder des films obscène alors
que j'ai déclaré que je ne pouvais plus
rester que j'allais faire mes valises et
un jour partir alors il manque passée à
tabac mais j'ai insisté
peu importe comment me battais je ne
resterai pas dans cette maison c'est un
endroit abominable il fallait que je
parte
peu importe ce que ça devait me coûtait
juste avant mon départ ils m'ont battu à
nouveau
[Musique]
j'ai quitté cette maison je suis rentré
chez moi je suis allé à la police
j'ai porté plainte contre ceux qui
m'avaient emmené dans cette maison ils
étaient deux les policiers ont mené une
enquête après cela ces deux hommes sont
revenus et ils ont tué mon père
[Musique]
avec maintenant je ne fais rien je reste
à la maison depuis la mort de mon père
je m'occupe de toutes les tâches
domestiques et oui je fais toujours des
cauchemars
j'ai toujours peur ils ont fait ça à mon
père c'était un homme adulte et moi je
suis encore une enfant
c'est pour ça que j'ai peur ça m'effraie
toujours
[Musique]
il ne nous reste que cette vidéo avec
lui elle a été filmée le dernier jour
lorsqu'il rentrait à la maison ils
marchent le long de la route et il joue
et il a déjà dépassé la caméra à en
juger par son comportement il se dirige
vers la maison
il n'est jamais rentré
[Musique]
d'habitude il rentrait seul à la maison
mais pas ce jour là alors je me suis mis
à appeler partout on l'a recherchée par
tous personne ne l'avait vu
[Musique]
j'étais épuisé j'ai cherché partout
personne ne sait où il se trouve
je me suis rendu à gourou g à balhaf
gare à faridabad à agra à matour à
algarve et même au rajasthan
les gens regardent une photo de lui et
disent qu'ils ne l'ont jamais vu on a
placardé 4500 photo de lui il a vu
quelque part comment
je les ai vus de loin oui il était loin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avez vous vu ce garçon
[Applaudissements]
vous vu ce garçon faut le chercher dans
le centre-ville où exactement là bas
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu ce gars sont ici
vous avez vu ce garçon
[Musique]
oh
vous l'avez vous vu là bas avec un chien
de sang il y a deux mois à peu près il
ya deux mois
ouais plus ou moins
[Musique]
on est allé partout il n'y a aucun
endroit délits qu'on n'est pas visiter
tout le monde dit la même chose on vous
fera savoir sur le trouve et on nous dit
la même chose au centre de secours at il
disparu il ya trois mois ou trois mois
et demi environ trois mois on vous
donnera un coup de fil si on le trouve
pas de soucier c'est le même garçon sur
les deux photos
non non on vous tiendra au courant si on
le trouve quelqu'un a dit qu'il avait
été repéré ici ils nous ont conseillés
d'interroger les gens aiment nous sourit
tous les mardis on y amène les enfants
perdus alors il faut y aller parce que
beaucoup d'enfants ils sont rassemblés
[Musique]
il
il aimait matin
[Musique]
maintenant nous ne pouvons plus le
rechercher comme avant
on n'a plus d'argent même pour faire le
plein d'essence pour la moto je n'ai
même plus la possibilité d'aller à sa
recherche en moto avant quand on avait
de l'argent c'était possible
[Musique]
et
il ya deux filles dans le train qu'il a
à bombay elles sont transportées
illégalement de bombay bien rejoindre à
la gare et sita mari avez vous des
informations à ce sujet
et
on va
mais vous venez du népal elle est avec
toi
vous êtes ensemble et lui il est aussi
avec toi il vous accompagne je ne sais
pas je connais pas son nom
[Applaudissements]
on
combien gagnez-vous par fille
il n'y a pas de prix fixe monsieur ça
dépend des gens pour qui elle travaille
alors il ya quelqu'un qui ça dépend de
leur générosité
ils décident eux-mêmes combien ils vont
payer ou emmener vous ces filles là
plusieurs endroits différents
qu'est ce que vous dites à leurs parents
lorsque vous venez les chercher à leur
domicile
on leur dit que tout va bien qu'elles
trouveront un bon travail et pourront
gagner bien leur vie ces femmes savent
tel ce qu'elles seront obligées de faire
comme travail
il m'a raconté qu'il me trouverai un
emploi et que je deviendrais actrice et
puis il a dit qu'il avait plus de sous
on a interrogé les filles on a eu
quelques conversations avec les filles
et nous avons appris que leurs familles
étaient très pauvres
elles sont jolies elles sont jeunes et
on leur promet qu'elles vont faire du
cinéma mais où travailler dans des
établissements de loisirs ou autres mon
boulot où elles vont faire beaucoup
d'argent
genre tu gagneras plus en quelques jours
seulement que tour et gagner ici durant
des années
c'est ce qu'on leur dit mais c'est un
mensonge mais comme un sale type
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'arrière
[Applaudissements]
et
quelqu'un parmi les connaissances de
prob où a appelé lui a dit qu'on avait
vu son fils dans les taudis à l'autre
bout de la capitale
nous avons sauté dans la voiture et nous
nous sommes précipités robot qui vous a
appelé une connaissance c'est notre
contact
il n'est pas sûr que ce soit l'enfant
que nous recherchons il dit peut-être
cet enfant est il venu de lui-même
oui allô oui on passe devant où on est
maintenant on va axa dame oui on y sera
dans une demi heure c'est moi qui sonne
s'il vous plaît est-ce que je peux
parler avec lui s'il vous plaît
salut où étais-tu ou têtu perdu mon fils
avec d'accord j'y vais j'arrive et
alors
petit par le moi s'il te plaît
oui tu es tu
d'accord j'arrive par le mois
ok d'accord
j'arrive j'arrive
allez
les chances de retrouver un enfant perdu
à delhi avec ses plusieurs millions
d'habitants sont extrêmement faibles
on va peut-être être témoin d'un vrai
miracle qu'est ce qui t'arrive et mon
fils où étais-tu ou regarde la caméra et
dealers je me suis perdu attend ici
[Musique]
faux
nous avons félicité pro bout et l'avons
laissée avoir un moment seule avec son
fils on a perdu tout contact avec lui
depuis lors
[Musique]
il semble qu'il n'existe pas de
statistiques généralisé concernant les
enfants séparés de leurs parents selon
la commission nationale des droits de
l'homme
44 mille mineurs disparaissent chaque
année la police déclare qu ils sont 88
mille enfants le fonds des nations unies
pour l'enfance unicef qualifie cette
situation de génocide et donne le
chiffre de 12 millions d'enfants